Wait...
Does this sound weird?
What's going on?
Oh, it sounds normal.
I think.
Welcome, welcome.
There's a ghost in my room!
Don't call an exorcist.
Hey, that's against the rules, actually.
You're not allowed to call...
You're not allowed to say any exorcism spells.
Or call an exorcist.
Or exorcise the ghost.
So...
Ban him!
No, just kidding.
Always press the button.
Oh, I forgot to write.
I wanna write...
Let's see...
One second.
Times of button pressed.
Let's see.
Let's have this up...
Right up top.
Right there!
Nice.
The button has been pressed...
Zero times!
No exercise, chubby mint?
No!
I exorcise!
I exorcise.
What are you talking about?
Get a functional rex, but snake comes to destroy it.
Sounds awesome, actually.
If snake shows up at all.
Win for me, baby.
If we can't exorcise the ghost, can the ghost at least exorcise?
Chubby mint, you say?
Shut up, all you degenerates.
Right now.
We're going to the chubby mint cafe.
Stop it!
Hush, hush, hush, hush.
You guys are unbelievable.
You hear the C word and you're just like...
Chubby?
Huh?
Stummy?
Stummy thighs?
Big?
Boobs?
I don't really know where I was going with that.
You're on activated.
No.
Anyway, what did I walk into?
Don't worry, please ma'am.
I just woke up.
Good morning!
I don't even know.
I'm still tired too.
I woke up and immediately...
Immediately Matara and I recorded.
So I'm quite sleepy myself actually.
And I...
I have some stuff I need to do today.
So sorry.
So I...
I...
Have an early stream today.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Kelly, welcome back!
NameSword, welcome back!
Gerard, welcome back!
ZenPlex, welcome back!
Amy, welcome back!
Thank you guys.
Eepy, eepy.
I know, I'm so eepy lately.
Recently I got a...
My cats like to wake me up very early to eat.
I recently got a...
A food bowl that will like open up at 2 am.
So that they will stop waking me up.
Because my one cat like scratches the door.
And it's just the most annoying thing ever.
So...
Textarium, welcome back!
Jeremy, welcome back!
I've also pressed the button.
Derpso, welcome back!
Arashi, welcome back!
Today we're pressing buttons.
You guys push my buttons.
Okay.
So this is...
A game?
It is a moral dilemma.
It is...
Life or death?
Or in my case, death or death?
Where with...
You give a...
You are given something good.
But...
It comes with a price.
The monkey paw curls.
And so...
Despite that...
That little...
That little finger...
Will you still push the button?
Will you be approaching these questions as made mint with made mint brain?
Or as made mint with a 12 year old gamer lad brain?
I think today...
We can have a...
A theme.
I would like to...
Maybe...
Every...
We can only push the button...
If it...
If...
What should the condition be?
We can only push the button...
If...
I don't know.
We'll come up with that as it goes.
Sorry.
My brain is not working today.
Press it for Henya.
So, let's start with our first one.
Because...
This one seems pretty...
Whatever.
I opened a website and this is what it said.
Well, you press the button.
You master every co-op multiplayer local game ever made.
That's like...
A lot of games.
Is this the button?
Am I pushing it?
Wrong button!
Push the red button.
It is shiny and red.
I agree.
But every word you type ends with an...
...
So, what's bad about that?
Is it just annoying?
Every word?
So it's like...
It's like that Spongebob episode.
Is that... wait, hold on.
I have to lean in.
Hold on.
Is that M or RN?
It's RN!
I thought it was an M!
Oh my god.
Saku!
Thank you for the...
I got my bonus today.
So it is time to spoil the Minto for all the fun times so far.
Stop!
Why do you write butaro like that?
It's some extra pads.
It's bu like...
Minto needs glasses?
Oh, I have my old contacts and stuff.
They're not mine today.
Also wasn't there an Akasupa?
Gosher!
Your Akasupa before stream!
I saw it!
Thank you!
So it's like, okay.
It's like that Spongebob episode.
I... don't...under...
stand...
...your... saying.
Like that.
Right?
I... don't...
...under...
Pfft.
Stand.
But instead, it's...
Babycore, thanks for the five gifts and...
Except...
What's so bad about this?
I would be amazing at games.
People would just think I'm annoying.
What's any different than now?
I would be the best there is to ever be.
But it's like...
Also, it's...
You master every co-op, multi-player, local game ever made.
Like, that's also...
That's also...
Like...
Why don't you just say every game?
Why don't you just say every game ever made?
But also...
I don't know.
Part of me is like...
Then you have no challenge to get better at games.
It's games made today, not games made in the future?
No one says ever...
Oh, wait.
Ever made ever?
Ever made from when?
Now?
Yeah, learning is fun.
But the money.
What?
Because I would be like a pro gamer?
People would definitely think I was cheating.
Tis himself.
Thanks for the ten gifted.
I guess not single player games.
Oh.
Oh, that's what they mean by local games then.
Ah.
Oh, my God.
I would be God at Mario Party.
I would be God at Mario Kart.
Local includes single probably.
That's what I was thinking though with the local.
But I guess if it means like local multi...
I don't know actually.
You would be an Apex Legend.
I'm already an Apex Legend.
I don't know if you guys know that or anything.
You could speed run Metal Gear.
I don't think I could ever speed run Metal Gear because the only way I would speed run Metal Gear is if I am given...
If I can watch the cutscenes because I cannot...
I physically cannot skip cutscenes.
I just love watching them so much.
Okay.
Let's see you in the next video.
Minto, new Apex Legend come, bear.
Yeah.
Dumb.
Got the stream before my bedtime.
Good night, Charles.
Thank you for always warning .
I've been a silent viewer for a long while.
I wanted to finally say thanks for all the laughs and good times.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Yeah.
New category, cut scene percent.
Sure, Jane.
It's Jan!
If you're gonna quote the line, get the name right.
It's not Jane, it was Sure, Jan.
Oh my god.
I've never seen anyone stream MGS4.
Not yet.
Just wait until I get back.
When we start our Metal Gear Solid journey.
Uh-huh-huh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Stop reading my typos.
Can't wait for the MGS4 watch-along.
Yippee!
No one can spell today.
Is it MGS4?
Is MGS4 locked behind a PS4?
Uh, no, PS3.
I have my PS3 for it.
Yes.
I have it.
I have it all set up.
I could play it right now if I would...
Actually, no, because I would have to set up.
I would have to set up everything.
But I could do it today if I even wanted to.
I could.
But then I would cry because it's MGS4.
Anyway!
You know what?
I don't care.
I don't...
You know what?
Multiplayer games...
I'm gonna assume that local games is like local, you know, like...
It's multiplayer, but it's not online multiplayer.
I'm not gonna assume that it's...
That it's single-player games.
I'm going to push the button.
Because...
Who cares if everybody just hears me go...
Mmm...
Every word ends with...
So, it's like...
Hey...
You...
Get good...
Wait...
Get...
Good...
At...
The...
Game...
Oh, it's R-N.
Shoot.
It's R-N.
Hold on.
Uh...
Get...
Good...
At...
The...
Game...
Oh, my gosh.
It would piss people off even more.
Oh, my god.
It would make people so angry.
Because they would be bad.
And then they would also see me typing so annoyingly.
Oh, my god.
Get...
Good...
Comment...
Pashamin...
Now...
What time is it?
Isn't it too early?
Are you okay?
Are you still...
Are you still not asleep?
Oh, my gosh.
It would be just like a plane.
Time to change all your passwords.
Oh, my gosh.
That would be so bad.
If my password leaked, you would know exactly what the last two letters of my password will be.
Her...
Metal...
Gear...
Gate...
My own...
It feels like I'm reading LulitSpeak or something.
It's so bad.
Hello, Maya!
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
But also...
You guys, I would have to make every...
I would have to make every tweet a voice tweet because nobody would want to read my tweets anymore because I don't understand a word she said.
Because every word that I would type would end in R-N.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Does this include business emails and stuff?
Okay, they would just think I'm really into the character, you know?
They'd be like...
Nobody would want to...
It's career suicide, but it doesn't matter.
All I have to do is speak.
It's only typing!
Press the button!
Oh!
Oh wait, hold on.
I have a button pressing thing.
There we go.
50-50.
50-50!
Would press the button!
That's so crazy!
50-50!
What would you guys do?
Would you press it?
Would you press the button?
You can do voice to text for a loophole.
So true!
I would not.
What's wrong with you guys?
Let's try the next one.
How is this an issue for me?
What is inside of my 있습니다?
It's too bad I can't do aan.
Wonder why everyone in my world could haveussed such an issue for everyone?
Butterfly is trying to survive in the world...
But...
It might beV
CHRIS isquesit All of my secret stans What?
Why did you not press the button?
It's a win-win, everybody!
Girls!
Girls rule the world!
Let's see...
When you press the button, you get a million dollars, but you have to spend one night, 9pm to 6am, in a sentient Walmart that's trying to kill you the entire time.
You can't bring in weapons, but you can use any weapons or objects you find in the store.
Well, luckily it's a Walmart, so...
There's already guns in there.
What are you talking about?
It's not even 20 minutes ago.
What do you mean?
For a million dollars though?
For a million dollars?
Hmm...
And then what?
9pm to 6am.
How long is that?
9 to 10, 10 to 11, 12... wait...
9 to 10, 10 to 11, 11 to 12, 12 to 1, 1 to 2, 1 to 2, 3 to 3, 3 to 4, 4 to 5, 5 to 6...
9 hours?
9 hours for a million dollars?
I mean, untaxed, right?
A million dollars doesn't really get you that... I mean, it's a lot, don't get me wrong, but like...
Hmm...
It's not like what it used to be, you know?
Like, it's not like what it used to be.
Oh, I didn't update the button counter.
You're right, thank you.
I pressed the button two times already.
Dang.
You still
have to pay taxes on this?
That's like risking my life!
What's the most dangerous thing in Walmart?
Walmart.
I absolutely would, no question.
But best case, get eaten by a sentient Walmart.
Worst case, I get a million dollars.
It says it's trying to kill you, but they didn't say...
They didn't say how you would die.
Because what if it is... I mean, if it's like...
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if the Walmart is like a monster girl?
Oh my god, wait.
Can I riz the Walmart?
Wait.
If it's like a, you know...
It's like a...
It's like a monster girl who's like...
Trying to, trying to, you know...
Wait.
Actually cooking?
Romance route?
Yeah, let her cook, yeah?
Like monster house?
Oh my god.
Like, you've seen those, like...
Where there's like...
It's like...
It looks like, you know...
Something unassuming, but it's actually a monster girl.
Thanks for the super time!
Thank you for the donut!
As a Canadian, I wouldn't have to pay taxes on the million.
But also as a Canadian, there would be no guns in the Walmart.
True, true, true.
It's a girl house.
So, let's see what the rest of this hacer will be like.
I mean, sentient Walmart.
And also, like, how is it trying to kill me?
Like, what's it doing?
Like, what, if I try to step outside, it closes the door on my foot?
Like, it doesn't...
It doesn't really make much sense, I feel.
Like, it feels kind of like...
What, what, do they control everything inside the Walmart?
Do they control everything inside the Walmart?
How can a Walmart kill you if you're already dead?
We're under the assumption that I'm alive, okay?
Which is really weird to think about, but...
You can see under Walmart's dress.
Raiders?
Oh!
I don't see, I don't see, I don't see...
Who raided me but thank you!
I think my pinned comment is blocking...
Sorry, yabe, I'm taking off your pinned comment.
I really liked it though.
Robo, thanks for the vibe gifted!
I'm cut.
I think this one is kind of... well, okay.
What if it's not a monster girl?
It will not push the button.
I think this one is kind of whatever.
54% did not.
I am of the majority.
He beat me a lot.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
What if it's two monster girls?
Andrey goes thanks for the 10 gifted!
Let's see.
Alright, let's try the next one.
You can create anything you think of in a matter of seconds.
It will be destroyed within 10 minutes.
Okay, this one seems way better than it seems worse.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Everybody's saying why not.
Everybody's saying press.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
You create your dream girl.
You create a cat girl.
You're just like, I can create anything.
I create animals.
I make girl in real life.
You fall in love.
You fall in love!
And then they're destroyed in 10 minutes!
No doubts.
Just create her every 10 minutes.
You have to...
Oh my gosh, what if she...
What if they like...
But it says destroyed.
That implies like she'll be in pain.
She'll be like destroyed, you know, in like a...
In like a painful, awful, terrible way.
She'll feel it every time.
Congratulations on your newborn son.
I created a son?
Giving her the ReZero experience.
You guys have a lot of opinions on this one.
Holy cow.
It's useful though.
I'd say it's more useful.
Think of food.
Eat food.
Food goes away after you're done.
No getting fat.
So if I just think of food...
Create con ticket, airplane ticket, money, etc.
So you use the money.
Oh my gosh, wait.
You use the money.
And then you...
Then you...
Then you pay for the thing.
And then it disappears.
It disappears.
It's...
Oh my gosh.
It's foolproof.
It's robbery.
It's highway robbery.
In a world where there is a ghost maid that is minty with a weird obsession of metal gear.
Thanks.
She's called mid-mid-chan.
Kimani.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Create a cold fusion reactor.
Study the design file patent.
What is a cold fusion reactor?
I'm scared.
What are you trying to create?
You can also create a disappearing murder weapon.
You know, I thought of that also too.
This is like the perfect way to commit a crime.
It has...
It definitely...
Thank you.
This definitely feels like it has more uses than not uses, right?
But also...
Isn't it that...
That...
Oh, it's infinite energy.
Oh.
But isn't it energy can't be created or destroyed?
So if you create something and it's destroyed within 10 minutes, where is it going?
It's just gone.
Magic.
Black hole.
What if it's making the black hole bigger?
I use this power to create this super I will disappear in 10 minutes mint.
I saw it.
Moerugomi.
You actually changed your name.
Create Oshii's open up meet and greet shop profit.
Thank you.
Chuu.
I'll call this waifu creation power.
51st creation dates.
The circle of waifu.
Okay fine.
We'll push the button.
Yeah, I figured most people would be pushing this.
We have pushed the button 3 times.
Okay, I'm going to give myself a limit.
I'm going to give myself a limit you guys.
I can only push the button 10 times.
We are going to have to be extremely Be extremely... careful about what we are pushing the button for.
What happens if you exceed it?
Then you guys can choose a punishment for me.
We'll think of a... maybe I'll have to do a punishment stream or a punishment tweet or something.
So.
So!
For these next ones.
I've already pushed it three times.
I've already pushed it.
I've been willy-nilly.
Okay, wait.
Two of them have been very good.
The seeing up this girl's skirts and see and push and creating anything.
I think both of those were good pushes.
I don't remember what the first one was.
How much for a comment section override?
What's that?
I don't remember what the first one was.
Oh!
It was the R.
I'm off to a con now.
Have fun everybody.
Remember, Minto is cute.
Thank you.
Have a good time at your con.
Okay.
You can have... Okay.
Will you press the button?
You can have any car you want for free and no problems attached.
Okay.
You can have...
Will you press the button?
You can have any car you want for free and no problems attached.
But every time you drive it for a total of one hour, your life gets shorter by one year.
I don't care about cars.
Do you guys... Are you guys car people?
I think I know... I think there's a few people maybe in the chat that are car people but...
Always be the passenger?
I'll hire a driver.
I like cars but no...
Thank you.
Like I don't... I don't think I've ever had like a dream car or anything like that.
So...
Create nanomachines.
Nanomachines creates more nanomachines.
Original nanomachines disappear.
New nanomachines make a new war.
Fist fight a cyborg on top of a giant robot.
Yeah!
Just sell it.
So it's every time I drive it, right?
So...
I could... Yeah, I could generate any car that I want.
But what if I like generate it?
What if I have it?
Oh wait, it's not generate it.
People might be like...
Where did you get that car?
I still don't think it's worth it though.
I don't care about cars.
Ka-chow!
Selling for money, especially rare ones.
That sounds like such a pain in the butt, right?
What if...
But then also...
You know...
Let's just...
Let's...
We don't know exactly how this works.
What if also the person driving it gets their life shorter by one year?
Do I have to disclose that?
Then nobody will buy them, you know?
Oh, it's also...
Wait, it says you can have any car you want for free.
No problem.
It says any car.
Is it unlimited?
Is it just one?
Who knows?
I'll sell it to my enemy.
It says you.
Yeah, but...
I don't know.
What if I accidentally drive the car and I don't realize it?
What if the car somehow comes back to me?
And I accidentally drive it.
And I drive it for like...
10 hours.
That's a long time!
Drive!
Just have my car and drive it.
Who do you think I was talking about when I said my enemy?
Ronan, thank you!
What if...
What if I...
Can you drive?
I can, I can drive.
I can, I can.
So...
It's the plot of a Stephen King book?
No way!
I...
There's one...
What's it called?
One...
There's only one Stephen King book that I can think of.
That involves some yabai stuff in a car.
Lifespan shortening is a pretty big problem.
For maybe a human.
But let's just assume I'm human in some of these.
Or in all of these, you know?
Let's just assume I'm alive and I'm well and I'm healthy.
At a ripe young age.
I don't think I will.
I don't like driving anyway, but I don't think I'm gonna press the button.
Oh, most people did not press the button.
That's crazy.
Okay, will you...
Come on.
Come on!
These are so...
Pulling the world peace card is just...
It's too...
It's too easy.
Come on.
Sci-fi...
World peace is achieved, but sci-fi, country, rock and metal music, video games and books are abolished.
This is so stupid.
This is so dumb.
Who wrote this?
Like a ten-year-old wrote this.
Also, it's like sci-fi...
Wait, sci-fi...
Is not a music genre.
This is so stupid.
I will not push the button because I don't want to give this kid the satisfaction.
But also, it's just like...
I've watched Macross and music will save the world.
I will not push the button!
Most people agree with me.
There are still sports.
Yeah, I skip out a protest.
Screw the world.
I need my escapism.
Yeah!
Get out of here, world peace!
Video games!
There's no video games.
I'm basically out of a job.
The world can burn.
Burn!
Break stuff is a metal song, so we would miss you singing that.
Yeah, without...
Yeah, exactly!
Exactly!
Also, why did they include...
Like...
These random assortment of...
Why didn't they just say music?
Why is it only country rock and metal music?
What about pop music?
What about...
I mean, that means like...
A lot of idols would still exist.
But why...
Yeah, no Metal Gear!
I would just...
I would rather...
I would rather die again.
No, no, no.
Anime is still in though.
Yeah, but you would have no anime openings.
An anime...
You would have no anime openings and closing songs.
Well, you would have only...
Yeah, if it's anisong...
Actually, if it's anisong...
What if it's a country anisong?
What if it's a rock anisong?
But it's classified under anisong.
I mean...
Hmm...
Found the loophole.
Still, I can't get over sci-fi.
I can't get over sci-fi.
Can't get over sci-fi.
Country anisong.
Oh, country...
Oh, yeah, there is country anisong.
Country roads.
This road.
Forever.
This isn't a video game.
It's an interactive story.
No more Konosuba endings?
That would be so sad.
No more Cyberpunk OST.
Is that sci-fi music?
It's a vicious cycle.
You get world peace but you have people starting wars to get back video games.
Yeah.
I need war so Metal Gear is created.
Just kidding.
That's because I'm a big fan of Super Cat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Hahaha.
Okay, next.
You press the button.
You get paid $20 an hour to play video games.
Okay.
The only games you can play are Mario Kart Wii, Farmville, the first one, Sonic 06, and Candy Crush Saga.
Uh, $20 an hour to play video games.
Someone said only $20!
What do you mean?
I mean, that's a lot.
That's a lot of money to play video games.
SonicOak6's peak present.
Not gonna lie.
I was thinking about streaming it somewhat recently.
What is Farmville?
Farm...ville.
What is this?
Play SonicOak6.
I live this.
Don't take the deal.
What are you talking about Hayden?
It's $800 a month?
Oh, I would definitely need another job then.
Right?
Wait, what do you mean $800?
Wait.
No, it's $20 per hour.
It's $20 per hour!
So if I play Candy Crush for...
For like...
Forever?
You know?
That would be... you know, it's per...
We're not... who's to say that I have to stop at 40...
Who's to say that I have to stop at 40... 40... 40 hours, right?
Who's to say?
You'll want to stop.
What do you do in Farmville?
It's a Facebook game?
A series of agriculture simulation social network games developed and published by Zynga in 2009.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I think my...
I think my... I think my... I think my... I think my...
I think my cafe is haunted.
My lights just flickered.
I've seen Vtubers play worse than this.
So you guys wouldn't hate if I became a...
A Farmville Mario Kart Wii Sonic 06 Candy Crush Saga streamer?
Can you Zoomer Max and have multiple Candy Crush gameplay windows on stream and get paid more?
Hell yeah.
I'd be down.
I'm clearing my schedule.
I would judge you but I would still watch.
Wait, if I was Mario Kart Wii, would you guys be able to play?
It would be sad there's no MGS.
Yeah, add Metal Gear in here.
No more Metal Gear.
Now I also wonder, the only games you can play are these.
Are they the only games that I can play to get paid?
Or can I...
Can I...
Can I also...
Play things without getting paid?
I wonder.
Lupin!
Can only to get paid?
No, only those ever?
It doesn't say.
It's unclear.
It's unclear!
I'd assume only those games at all.
Then I will not push the button.
Wow!
That's actually pretty close.
But you know what?
I get it.
If it's $20...
If you don't play video games very much and it's just like...
I don't care about video games.
And you're just like, I'm gonna make $20 an hour.
Which is good!
That's good!
To make good $20, right?
To make that...
I mean...
I...
I never made that much at a job.
So...
Yeah...
To do that...
Not so much anymore?
Really?
Depends on where you live.
Well, to me...
To me, it feels like a lot.
As a former game tester, it isn't worth it.
We have...
We have the...
The real testimonies of Trevor.
Thank you, Trevor.
$20 is $20.
So true.
Thank you.
Thank you for the $20.
Let's see.
What else?
What's the next one?
Okay.
Wait a second, though.
Hold on.
Before we get ahead of ourselves...
Before...
This game...
This...
This site is making me...
It's trying to turn me into a pervert, I think.
Hold on.
Before we get too excited...
You can see through all clothes.
One.
Can I turn this power off?
Two.
Can I decide whose clothes I want to see through?
You know?
I don't want to see through everybody's clothes.
Read the downside.
But you cannot turn the power off.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait a second.
I read the button when I first pushed this, but I thought it meant, like, the power...
Like, electricity power.
I thought it meant, like...
When you...
When you're trying to...
When you're trying to sleep, the lights are left on.
Mean greet would be awkward.
No!
You guys, nobody would come to my mean greet knowing that I'm staring at them naked.
Or maybe you would, you little freaks.
Maybe you would.
You'd be like, oh my god.
I'm into seeing my naked body right now.
Wouldn't you feel self-conscious, though?
I totally would.
You little freaks.
But you can't turn the power off.
So I just see everybody's naked.
Eventually, at some point...
At some point...
Oh my gosh, no.
I will not push this.
Because...
Clothing is sexy, everybody, okay?
Clothing is sexy.
That would mean no more bunny girl outfits.
No more maid outfits.
No more...
No more swimsuits.
Nothing.
It would just be naked bodies everywhere.
That's not sexy at all.
It would be so boring.
Then I would just be so sad.
No cosplay ever, ever, ever, ever.
I would be so sad.
Oh my god.
No!
I just...
This sounds really...
Anybody who pushes this button is so sad, I think.
I think.
But...
Man...
It's actually a wholesome reason.
Is it...
Is it wholesome for me to want to be like...
Um...
To be like...
What do I...
To...
To be obsessed with cosplay?
Is that wholesome?
I'm not sure.
But anyway...
I will not be pushing the button.
Okay.
See?
Three out of ten times so far.
Oh!
Most people did not push the button.
Very good.
Also, there's a comment.
The first comment on here says, what if you can't find your own clothes because you can't see them?
That's true.
Because other people wouldn't have the power.
And you can't find your own clothes.
You can't find your own clothes because...
Because you can't see them.
And then you can never go outside because...
What do you...
Wait, I guess you would have to wrap yourself in a blanket all the time.
Blankets not clothes.
Found the monkey paw.
I feel like a...
I feel like a kid wrote this question too.
Next.
Will you press the button?
You can fly but you can't speak anymore.
And tweet like a bird.
So I'm like...
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
Like that?
Or...
Should I become a bird?
Sign language?
You can fly but...
Hmm.
Yeah, you could just learn sign language, right?
Or...
Or tweet...
Or sound like a bird.
Talk with chat GPT.
No.
Yeah, tech.
You mean text to speech.
Yeah, use a keyboard.
And then you can fly.
Flying is like the best power ever.
Right?
I can flow.
I can fly a little bit.
But not like...
I can't...
Not so good.
You're already fly AF.
Oh my gosh.
Magic doodoo Johnson.
Thank you.
I'm like...
She's so fly.
Chirp, chirp.
Fly away.
Oh my gosh.
You can flow.
Yeah.
Flying is dangerous power but can be fun.
Why do you think it's dangerous?
Speak Vocaloid.
Because like...
Teleport is better?
No.
I think...
Even still, I think I would rather fly than teleport.
Depending on like how you're able to fly, right?
Because...
If it uses like a lot of energy, then of course then teleporting might be better.
But like...
If you're flying, it's nice.
Unless it's raining or something.
I don't know.
If the weather is good, you're just like...
You're in the clouds and it's nice and breezy and you enjoy the journey.
I guess it depends.
You enjoy the journey or not.
When I tweet, can I communicate with other birds?
This is important.
That's true.
Do I gain bird powers?
Can I control the pigeon?
I like mince boys.
Yeah, you lay eggs.
Wait.
Free food.
If I lay eggs and I eat them, is that eating my own children?
Well, they're not fertilized eggs.
So...
Maybe it would be okay.
I don't know.
I think...
Yeah.
Unfertilized.
So no.
Yeah.
More like eating your own placenta.
People do that, though.
They eat their placenta once they have a baby.
I think.
Right?
That's the placenta, right?
Haruka, welcome back.
Doomguy!
Thank you for the five gifts.
Thanks, Haruka.
I've heard of that.
Yeah, I've heard of that too.
Placenta hot dogs.
I'm gonna start selling my eggs.
Wait, not my eggs.
Wait, I don't... wait.
If I were to lay eggs, I would sell my eggs, but I would cook them as hot dogs.
If Finlay's egg is a ghost egg, like a hollow plastic Easter egg...
Then... but it would be kinda gooey, I think.
Hmm... egg glizzy.
Let's see...
The only thing... well, I guess, like you said, you can't speak anymore, but that doesn't matter.
That won't... wait!
You can't speak anymore.
But that won't stop me from singing!
They didn't say I couldn't sing!
Yippee!
It's the loophole!
I'll take ten hot dog eggs.
Hatsune Minto.
I am Burb.
We can...
We are quite communicative.
Also, you could write.
Yeah, exactly!
But all of this... this is a lot to trade off for being able to fly.
Do you guys think being able to fly is worth it?
I think I... I think I kinda do.
I think I kinda do.
I remember when I was a kid, I used to be able to wish I could fly.
I used to be able to say... I used to say, I wish I could fly...
Um... I used to say I wish... well, I used to say I wish I had, um...
A... um...
A cloud like Goku.
Guys, I only have ten!
Think of all the omurice for the cafe.
You're so right.
We could save on so much...
So many resources.
I've already pressed it three times.
If I press it one more, there'll be four.
That's how math works!
Okay.
I'll press it.
Bing bing.
What?
Most people said no?
Oh, that's crazy.
Really?
Okay.
Such a bad deal, you think so?
I would say no too, but I wanna fly.
Fine then.
Let's go to the next one.
Okay.
While you press the button, you have an internal tracking device inside your brain that finds anything...
That you... you lose.
But everybody... everyone knows of you having this power and every day there are people asking you to find some of their belongings.
Basically the plot of The Little Mermaid for Lando.
You're so right.
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait.
So you have an internal tracking device inside your brain that finds anything that you... you lose.
But everybody knows of you having this power and every day there are people asking you to find some of their own belongings.
So it's only... it's not people.
You could charge people.
I could charge people.
Micmac!
Thanks to the five gifted!
We could... we could monetize this.
Yeah, this seems like a really good business opportunity.
Who's you, you?
I don't know!
Maybe they meant Yunyun.
From Konosuba.
But it's only belongings.
Um...
Huh...
Uh oh, I feel like I should press the button again.
I feel like this is a good deal.
Hey Mint, have you seen my phone?
Yeah, have you looked up your butt?
Wait, do you remember when kids used to say up your butt and around the corner?
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if someone's like, hey I haven't seen my mom.
And it's like, oh yeah.
She's in my room.
Heya!
People stop saying that?
Do people still say that?
Anton, welcome to membership, thank you.
Have you seen my wallet?
Yeah, have you checked?
Have you checked?
Up your butt?
What if I just tell everybody up their butt?
But it's only for what you lose.
Not for what they lose.
I think it's just worded poorly.
Because then why would people be asking me about it?
Suck, suck, suck, suckle dragon!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Don't do it, it'll never end!
Honestly...
Um...
I don't lose that much stuff.
Actually, that's not true.
I lose my phone all the time.
I think I'm gonna have to decline.
Just because...
The wording is kinda bad.
Forgot to join last month.
My bad homie.
No!
Thanks so much!
Okay.
What happens if crazy people threaten you?
I charge them more.
I say pay up.
Pay up!
Alright, I- I just- The wording is bad.
So, I will not...
Wow!
Most people pushed it.
Maybe because they also feel like they could monetize it.
Maybe they also are just like...
Yeah, I make a killing.
One, you're not forced to say yes.
Two, charge them if they want to.
Yeah...
Give them incorrect information.
But what if they come at me then?
What if they're just like...
You were wrong!
What if someone comes... oh my gosh, what if the government starts asking me where it is...
Oh my gosh, what if they're like, where is Amelia Earhart?
Where is Amelia Earhart's plane?
Where is...
Where is Cleopatra's tomb?
Sorry, those are on my brain because I was telling Mithal earlier about Cleopatra.
Where's my super suit?
Where is Metal Gear?
Oh my god.
Metal Gear?
Where is Carmen?
Where in the world is Carmen Sandiego?
Thanks for a month!
Okay, let's try the next one.
Will you press the button?
You would be the most popular person in town.
The only social network you could use would be Google+.
I don't think you have... Google Plus is not around anymore, right?
How old is this?
Google Plus is gone.
This one is old.
Ancient tech.
But like, you're the most popular person in town.
Also, like...
I don't...
Um...
You guys, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna be posting all of my streams from now on from Google+.
Good luck, everybody.
B2B5!
Oh, thanks for the...
Thank you so much.
You're already popular?
Stop it.
Google Plus ceased in 2019.
It was only 2019?
It feels like it was so much older than that.
Is it even still operational?
I don't think so.
Did you guys have Google Plus?
Did you guys have... I think I tried using Google Plus.
I think because several idols that I liked started using it.
I was like, fine, I'll use Google Plus.
Being popular is a curse, though.
I don't wanna be... I don't want people...
I don't think I wanna be popular in the town.
I think I will not push the button.
I don't think... I think I'm good.
I think I don't wanna be the most popular person.
I think I'm okay.
It can be back then used Google+.
Yeah, that's exactly what...
That's exactly why I used it.
Some of the AKB girls that I liked were using it, so...
Okay.
Didn't they force YouTube accounts to Google Plus and change back?
I don't know anything that Google is ever doing.
They confused the heck out of me.
It's so weird.
Anyway, I will not be... I don't care.
Yeah, most people...
Oh my gosh, there's comments on here from 8 years ago.
This is so old.
This one comment.
I hate attention.
And I couldn't use Tumblr?
Hell no.
Oh my God.
I couldn't use Tumblr?
Oh no.
How else will I find out the ranking of the Tumblr sexy man?
Oh my gosh.
I heard recently that...
That Castiel...
Or Distiel...
Distiel has been dethroned from...
From Tumblr.
I've heard.
Gee, Witch Sweep.
Yeah!
Distiel was dethroned off of...
Off of Tumblr by Sule Mio.
It's so crazy.
Which is the...
Which is...
Which is Soletta...
Soletta and...
Wait.
It's Gundam.
Gundam Witch.
Witch for Mercury.
There we go.
It's them.
Isn't that...
I was like Gundam?
Gundam.
I know...
I knew...
I knew Gee Witch was really popular but I didn't think it was so...
So, so popular.
I still need to get around to watching it.
I see.
Goodbye, Distiel.
Distiel.
When you press the button, everyone works for you but there's always a rebellion.
Rebellion.
Wait.
This is so funny because...
This is literally just...
This is literally just Chetino in Blue Archive.
This is just Chetino in Blue Archive.
Where...
Everybody...
Full archive moment.
I know!
Hell yeah.
I pushed the button.
Rebellion!
Maybe I got a little too excited about that one.
I've already pushed the button five times.
But that's okay.
You have 10 million followers, but they're all on MySpace.
Hey, I'm friends with...
Oh gosh, what was his name?
Mike?
Who is the MySpace guy?
The Patriots with Les Enfants Terribles be like...
Tom!
I'm friends with Tom, and that's all I need.
He's my friend.
Oh, he's my friend!
If you want to be Cherino, you have to put on a mustache.
Do I even have a mustache?
Actually, I don't even know if I have one.
I think I must have one.
I must have one.
I don't have one in...
In white, though.
Rebellion!
Whispies of the world unite.
You guys wouldn't rebel against me, though.
The only thing we have to lose are our aprons.
Everyone works for you, but there's always a rebellion?
That's just chat?
You guys wouldn't rebel against me.
You would be so happy.
Right?
Every time I blink, my mustache jumps.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Viva la rebellion!
Vick Boss!
That's what you should be saying instead.
Oh my god, it's the world peace question again.
The world will have no war, disease, destruction, and famine for the rest of its days, but the USA will be wiped out from existence.
We'll meet again.
Don't know where and don't know when.
I know we'll meet again, some sunny day.
What was it?
That was... What was it?
What was that movie?
Strangelove!
I must ask you a question, but I shave it for later, mate.
Thank you.
I'm not taking questions at this time.
Whisper, whisper, whisper.
Dr. Strangelove?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like... I feel like... I hate world peace questions just because I feel like it's a low blow.
You know?
I feel like it's not so interesting.
Let's just fall out.
I'm not wasting my press, you guys.
Yeah, they aren't fun.
I feel like they're just kind of like... whatever.
It's like... world peace.
Or...
It's like world peace, but... you lose fun!
Haha!
There's world peace!
Nobody would go against world peace!
That's what I feel like.
Everybody who creates these questions are just like...
If you go against world peace, you're... you're terrible!
You're... you're horrible!
Why would you deny world peace?
It's just like... because...
You know.
So it's lame.
So I do these out of protest.
Let's just ignore it.
World peace, but you lose sci-fi.
Will you press the button?
You get an Alienware laptop.
But you can never download games!
Okay, this is also... the top comment is 8 years ago.
Okay, sundowner.
Oh my god, this is so funny.
This is so...
Hahaha!
Whoever created this was just like...
Alienware is the top...
The top of the top.
Did I tell you guys I got a new laptop?
I'm still setting it up.
But I got a new laptop.
It's a...
It's a Lenovo one.
World peace is real!
Peace day never came!
Is it Alienware?
Hahaha!
But yeah...
I got a new one, so...
I will have it for streaming when I'm in Japan and stuff.
Yeah, it's the Lenovo Legion!
It's the Lenovo Legion.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
It's the Legion, it's the Legion.
Which I was actually recommended before when I bought a laptop previously.
And I went with the previous laptop and it was so bad.
But I heard a lot of good reviews about this one.
So...
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
You get a Lenovo laptop but you can never download games.
Hahaha!
Yeah, hashtag not sponsored.
But...
Yeah, so...
The last two laptops have been Lenovo.
I think honestly, like...
Honestly, no matter what kind of...
What kind of laptop or PC or...
Well, not PC, I guess.
Whatever laptop you get...
There's always...
People always have issues.
Some issues with some things, so...
Mmm, mmm.
Let's hope it's good.
I hope so too.
So far, it's been actually so much better than my previous one.
So...
I am already...
I'm already feeling good about it.
I'm already feeling better about it.
I was watching...
I was thinking about getting the...
Umm...
What is it?
The...
ROG...
Uhh...
What's...
What's the...
Not the...
Not the laptop.
Oh, wait.
Blue archive.
Umm...
The ROG Ally!
Yes!
I was thinking of getting one.
And then I saw a video on it recently.
And actually...
One of the laptops I was looking at...
Looking at too...
Was a ROG.
And I'm kinda glad I didn't get it.
Because...
Umm...
Oh...
Some...
Oh my gosh.
If...
If you haven't seen the video...
I was like...
I was so shocked.
You saw the video.
Yeah, I saw the video.
But I was thinking of getting the ROG Ally.
And then...
Umm...
I didn't.
But also...
A laptop I was looking at was ROG as well.
So I was like...
Fuh uh...
Dodge the bullet, maybe!
Hmmaaannnn...
Ya.
But...
It was a while ago that I was thinking about it.
I got the...
I got a steendeck instead.
I can play Metal Gear on it.
This reminds me of another question.
Unlimited bacon and no video games?
Or unlimited videogames and no video games.
What kind of bacon?
Cause I've only lived in escalators.
I don't like turkey bacon.
Did you get the OLED Steam Deck?
No.
I'm still rocking my original Switch.
Still got the old Steam Deck.
Maybe I'll upgrade after a while.
Legion is nice because they have tons of ports.
It's not so heavy and it's much bigger than my last one.
I think I'm gonna be able to stream on it pretty easily.
I'm really excited.
I was really excited getting it.
Might be a good idea to do a test stream before you leave if you have time.
Last streamer I watched got a new laptop for a trip.
Ended suffering being bad than expected.
Yeah!
That's a good idea.
Maybe I will.
I'll do a test stream before...
It won't be like a real stream.
It'll be a test stream.
I'll do like a short test stream before I go.
Thanks for the idea!
You guys, do I push the button on the Alienware laptop?
You guys...
It's Alienware laptop.
You guys!
It's Alienware laptop!
But I can never download games.
What's the point of getting a gaming laptop if you can never download games?
What else would you do with it?
Browse Facebook?
Sorry, I'm thinking of 8 years ago.
Okay, hold on.
Put your mind in 8 years ago.
Which...
Sell it.
Okay, so the way this is worded...
It says you can never download games.
Does that mean you can never download games again?
Or you can never download games on the Alienware laptop?
These... The people that write these...
They need to be more specific because I have questions.
There are loopholes that...
That must be answered.
It's too vague!
I think...
I think we'll pass.
Maybe.
Everybody...
Everybody in consensus.
Oh my gosh.
What is it?
Alien...
You know what?
My first...
When I first started streaming...
It was...
Alienware...
It wasn't...
I...
I spent a lot of money...
on my Alienware laptop, you guys.
When I first...
Back in 2020...
I spent a lot of money on...
You know what?
This button is for me.
This question is for me.
Because...
Was it worth it?
Well, I mean...
Actually, I still have the laptop.
It treated me well.
It was a little hard to stream.
No games?
No way.
Did you make this question?
Yeah.
And you could still download games.
I could.
I downloaded them.
Yeah.
Lady Mint.
Integrated games are included and browser games are okay.
But what is...
What counts as an integrated game?
Minesweeper?
That explains so much.
Hey!
I...
How much did I make at my job?
I saved up a lot of money for my model and for my laptop.
I made...
I think I made $13 an hour at my office job.
I think I made $13 an hour.
And my model...
I remember...
I think...
I went with the lower pricing for my first model.
I cannot remember how much it was.
I think rigging was about $200 or $300.
And then with my laptop and I had to get a mic and the...
And the...
I originally...
I originally used a mic on my headphones.
This is pre-2018 so it makes sort of sense.
What, the question or me?
No, but this was in 2020 for me.
This was 2020.
So...
Some people might remember the headset mic.
I only used it for like...
I don't know.
I don't know what I said.
Like three streams or something.
But everybody complained about it so much...
Well, not complained, but everybody commented about it so much that I spent it then.
I then got a...
I then got a mic and an interface.
Toaster Mike, the OG!
Yeah!
It was a mic on a headset.
And then I still have the fan that everybody helped fund me to get to.
The Dyson fan.
I still use it to this day.
So...
All the way back...
Back then...
Back then there were less of you guys but...
But you guys helped me a lot by...
By helping me be able to get the fan that I needed because I was stuck in my closet and it was really really hot.
And I couldn't stream for a long time because I would get heat stroke.
And...
Um...
Do you recommend the Dyson fan?
I'm starting to get hot here.
Oh my god.
I've tried...
I have tried searching for this fan.
I think they discontinued it.
It is the...
It is such a good...
It is such a good fan.
It is small enough for it to like be on my desk.
And it keeps me so cool and it's so quiet.
And it was...
It was not so expensive.
It was like 200...
I mean for a fan it's very expensive.
It was like 250 something dollars I think.
So...
Um...
Uh...
What's the model?
Hold on.
Uh...
It's the...
Dyson Cool?
It doesn't have a model on it.
I'm picking it up right now.
Wait.
Air multiplier technology.
Yeah.
And it's...
250 for a fan?
Well, if you think about it...
Like...
I needed something really, really quiet.
And...
Yeah.
It's a bladeless fan.
I needed something quiet.
I was worried about something that would like...
You would hear too much on stream.
And...
Yeah.
It's one of the bladeless ones.
It's so...
It's so great though.
It's...
It was so...
I swear.
Like I'm so...
Every time I use it, I think of you guys.
I'm so grateful for it.
Because it's just so...
It's just so nice.
So thank you.
I'm like hugging it right now.
Oh, my fan.
I love you, fan.
And it like tilts.
It tilts and it has a little remote control.
And it also like...
Goes back and forth.
Oh my gosh.
This was like...
It was like...
This was...
I think...
One of my...
This was like my first big purchase as a streamer.
So I was like...
I'm still...
It's like my baby.
It's my...
It's my favorite thing.
So I was just like...
Oh, my gosh.
You guys worked so hard to help me be able to get the fan.
So it's like my...
It's like my...
You know.
It's my...
It's my precious.
I think of it.
I think of you guys when I...
When I use it.
It's like my...
It's like this.
I'm like...
I'm going to turn it on right now.
Where's the remote?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
You hear that?
No, you don't.
Oh, my gosh.
So I can't say...
I'm at work.
Just want to show support.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks for every time.
Thanks, Pepsi.
Good luck with work.
Kind of like a trophy.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
How did you save up for all this stuff when the idols are right there?
I um...
I...
You know...
You might think that I'm like blowing my whole paycheck on idols.
But quite honestly...
Quite honestly, my idols...
I can't buy so much from them.
They mostly just put out stuff when it's in Japan.
So if I were in Japan...
I would be like...
Everything would go to them probably.
Hey, you're a simp.
Yes, thank you.
In the past, I used to think that...
That your simp line was directed at you guys like as a joke.
But now I think it's just fully me.
I can't believe that Mint is a favorite fan and it isn't any of them.
What are you talking about?
Anyways guys...
I will be pushing the button for the Alienware laptop.
I'm kind of curious.
I want to kind of skew the ratio a little bit.
I want people to press this and be like...
Say, I will not.
What the hell?
Who would press the button on this?
And then realize how green...
Everybody, if you get this question on willyoupressthebutton.com...
Push the button so we can skew it to 90%.
Okay?
What?
Wait.
That's so many more people.
I thought it was going to be like 2%.
What?
No way.
That's insanity.
But also the top comment says...
You can never download games.
Okay.
I'll just get someone to do it for me.
Lupo.
Wow.
That's so funny.
Like, you guys.
I'm getting an Alienware laptop.
Whoopie doo.
Let's see.
All right.
Will you press the button?
You have your perfect body.
But everyone thinks you're hideous.
Um...
Oh my god.
Stop.
The first...
The comment on this is so...
I don't know.
This is so sad.
The top comment...
Or the top comment on this is so sad.
I pressed the button.
I am older and not attractive anymore anyways.
Nobody looks at me anymore.
And I am in poor health.
Having the perfect body would make me healthy again.
Plus, I don't care what people think anyway.
What?
No.
That's actually so sad.
Oh my god.
I didn't expect to cry at the button.
No way.
Too real comment.
Man's going through it.
It's so sad.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Um...
I have my perfect body.
What is my...
Oh wait.
It says...
So it's like in health or just like in...
In...
Physi...
Like what I have...
How big...
How big the...
How...
You know...
Actually, I don't really want them too big.
Flat is justice after all.
Wait.
How flat?
How flat can they be?
Let me see.
Snakes physique.
Perfectly flat.
Oh.
Concave.
I'm going to turn into like a black hole.
Yes.
Medium is pretty easy.
Any prize?
I mean any size is a prize everybody.
Any size is a prize.
And you take that to the grave.
You take that home.
Any size is a prize.
Amen.
Can I get an amen?
Everyone will think you're hideous.
Or everyone will think you're hideous.
I think I don't care.
I don't care how I look as long as I can see cute girl.
So... become a Vtuber after.
I become... I become so ugly but I become a Vtuber.
That's why I'm a Vtuber.
People who can show their face is scary.
Just be a Vtuber.
But also... I mean... my perfect body.
I don't feel like I...
I don't feel... I mean not to say that... I don't... like I don't really have a perfect body.
I don't even know what that means.
I don't even know.
I heard every size is a fry.
I was confused.
We should talk about some McDonald's.
Cup sizes are grade... letter grades.
A premium... A premium beef.
A plus plus.
What about S?
What if... what if they start incorporating S into school?
A5.
They should.
I would...
S for sorry.
Yeah, S equals 100.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How big is a S boob?
S boob size.
Oh, it's not showing me.
I'm seeing a G.
G, G, F.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
It says yours, so it means what you want to look like.
My belief is there is beauty in imperfection.
Wow, Doomguy.
You're so... that's so philosophical.
Wow.
Thanks, Doomguy.
Personally, I'll press.
I don't think I'm going to press because I don't really know what a perfect body feels like.
Or, like, I don't know what I would want.
Could I be, like, a gelatinous mash?
Like a... like a slime girl?
Would that count?
Could I be, like, a slime body?
Snake girl body?
I think people would think I'm hideous if I'm a snake girl.
If that's perfect, then...
To you.
Ectoplasm body?
I feel... I get... I become that after stream.
I use up all my energy and I'm just like...
Turn into... turn into slime.
You know?
Okay.
I'm not going to press the button.
And I'm a ghost.
I don't really care.
Wow, most people did not press it.
72%.
Wow.
Next.
Anime!
Will you press the button?
You get to publish a manga or create an anime with whatever storyline you want.
But the manga art is terrible.
Or anime is in terrible English dub.
Okay.
Yeah, but what about the Japanese dub?
What about the... what about the Japanese version?
Who... who's the seiyuu?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Publish a manga or create an anime with whatever storyline you want.
Whatever I want?
Google says JP cup sizes go up to 2.5 cm per letter.
So a 55S has an overbust of 105 to 107.5 cm.
41...
0.5 to 42.5 inches.
I've definitely seen that size.
On my... on... on... on... um...
DeviantArt.
This is literally One Punch Man.
You're a seiyuu.
Slime girl mint bottle buns.
Oh, thank you.
Some terrible English dubs are amazing.
Yeah, right.
Hmm...
The top comment on this is, I just don't like manga and anime.
So I don't really care.
Oh, no.
This is about anime.
Oh, my gosh.
What would we create?
Well, recently I thought of an anime idea.
Kind of.
I was like... I was like kind of cooking.
I was like...
I was on the train in Japan.
And I was like...
Looking out the window.
I was standing and like just watching things.
And I thought of like a...
Like either a four coma type anime.
Or like a short...
You know how some... some anime like have really short episodes.
Something really short.
And I was like...
What if there was like an anime...
It would be like kind of slice of life.
It would be really cute.
Kind of cozy.
Like Yuru Camp.
But like...
When I was on the train, I was like...
Looking out the window.
And just kind of seeing...
Little flashes of...
Stuff that would be going on.
Little like bits of life.
So like...
It would be like...
We'd go by...
I don't know.
Like a...
Like I would see...
I would see...
Something...
Like a...
Someone walking their dog or something.
You know?
And in my brain, I was like creating a whole story about them.
I was just like...
They're walking their dog.
And their dog...
Runs away.
And...
Bumps into another guy walking their dog.
And then they fall in love.
And it becomes...
And I was like...
What if there was like an anime about...
A girl who was like...
Looking out the window.
And would see little blips of life.
And then she would also come up with her own stories.
For like...
What people are...
Like...
But they'd be crazy.
You know?
So it's like...
Just like 101 Dalmatians.
Yeah!
And it's like...
They have like a...
So she sees like someone doing their laundry.
And she just comes up with the whole...
Like...
Little story line in her head about like...
You know...
It's like...
What is...
I don't know.
It was...
It's a very...
Loose idea.
That I think...
Came up with...
Like...
When I was in Japan.
And I was thinking about it.
I was like...
What?
Like...
How...
How would I be able to turn this into an anime?
Daydreamers Delusions.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
That sounds like such a good title!
Wow!
That's so cute!
Oh my gosh!
That sounds so cute!
Pichitamapa.
No!
So...
Yeah.
Sounds a little like Nichijou.
I guess you're right.
Yeah.
But it was like...
It was like...
Very short...
In my brain.
Because it's like...
You can't really turn a show.
And then like...
Maybe another person enters the train.
And like...
She also has her weird...
Delusions.
We're all just all having our delusions.
You know?
Have Ayami-sensei draw the manga.
I think it would end...
In my brain, it's a little more say-so than that.
I think with how Ayami-sensei would draw it...
It would become...
It would...
That's the plot of Gekkan Shoujo Nozaki-kun.
Is it really?
Oh!
I've never actually seen Nozaki-kun.
But mine all takes place within a train.
Anyway, what was it?
Oh yeah.
Publish a manga or create an anime with whatever storyline you want.
Okay.
Storyline I want.
Um...
Me.
It starts out with me.
I'm Mint Phantom.
And you might be...
You might be wondering...
How did I get into this situation?
Where...
There's girls...
I'm at a...
I'm at a bathing suit...
Wet t-shirt contest.
And...
Oh fuck.
Push the button.
Okay.
You guys, I only have three more tries to push the button.
They only have three more to push the button.
What's wrong?
Oh gosh.
It's okay.
The JP...
The Japanese version...
The English dub is fine.
I don't care if it's bad.
I just need...
I just need the Japanese to be good.
And even if the manga art is bad...
It's fine.
If it's a ghost story style dub, I will push the button in a heartbeat.
So true.
Anyway...
Will you press the button?
You'll be able to create your own reality at any time.
But after twenty-five uses, you will be stuck in your own reality and not be able to go back to the original world.
Easy press...
Press the button and call Kojima.
It's time for Metal Gear in the anime.
Oh my god, Kiefer Sutherland's back!
He's voicing all of Snake!
Oh no!
Not to say he was bad, but you know, not having David Hayter would probably make it bad, right?
I feel like there's no downside to this, right?
Be able to create your own reality at any time.
Like, what's the downside?
25 uses, you just keep track, bozo.
But also, you only need one use.
Yeah, I'm kind of confused.
What if you like...
What if you...
If you create your own reality, you're controlling everything in it, are you not?
Like, reality...
If you're creating your own reality, whatever you want, then it's like...
Just use it 24 times and save the 25th to reset everything if necessary.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I'm only gonna have two more prices.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, I figured most people would press this.
I figured most people would press this.
Yeah, makes sense.
Like, how is it a choice?
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Oh!
Well, you press the button.
You are never sick, but you are always exhausted.
I might as well be sick!
I might as well be sick, right?
What do you mean I'm always exhausted?
No!
I will not press the button on that.
That sounds crazy.
That's me now.
No!
I'm always exhausted anyways, Satch.
Well, then you could push it.
Because then, you know...
Different...
But there will be some day that you're not always exhausted.
But if you push the button, you'll always be exhausted, you know?
There will come a time when you are not exhausted, you know?
And so, that will be a time that happens.
And at that time, you'll feel so much better and you'll feel so good and feel so much relief.
Next!
Will you press the button?
You can watch any book as a film in your head, but Kristen Stewart is the lead actor.
What's wrong with that?
Kristen Stewart as Solid Snake?
You can watch any book as a film in your head.
What?
Who?
Kristen Stewart?
She is the girl that played...
I think...
Is this like around Twilight era or something?
She is the girl that plays Bella Swan in Twilight.
This is such a 2012 thing.
It really is.
What's wrong with Kristen Stewart?
I see no downside.
But I also see no upside.
I mean, Kristen Stewart is fine, but like Shrek...
Oh yes, my favorite novel, Shrek.
Oh yes.
I love... I love reading the classics.
To Kill a Mockingbird.
The Great Gatsby.
Shrek.
Shrek is an old book actually?
Huh?
Shrek is based on a book?
Wait, really?
Shrek the Novel.
Shrek!
With an exclamation point!
1990?
Shrek is a fantasy comedy picture book published in 19...
What the...
The book served as the basis for the first Shrek film.
It's a Shrek with an exclamation point.
But is it a... wait, is it a...
Oh, it's a picture book though.
It's a picture book everybody!
It's a picture book!
I don't think picture books count.
I don't think picture books count because...
Because...
I don't think picture books count because they're pictures.
Should only be books, books, books.
Sammy, thanks for the one month.
Thank you!
I'd do it to see her play Bilbo Baggins.
Kristen Stewart as Jesus in the Kingdom of the Bible.
It says any book?
That means manga doesn't count.
Yeah, probably...
No, manga shouldn't count either.
I think it should be only books, books.
Not picture books.
Not comic books.
Just book books.
Regular books.
I cannot believe that there's a Shrek book.
What is going on?
This isn't real.
Is this a real part of the book?
Hold on.
The picture looks legit, though.
I don't think this is real.
Shrek was still hungry, so he ate a bolt of lightning.
Yum, said Shrek.
My diet is everything.
You eat my food, said the cloud that made the lightning.
Please at least tip 20%.
Okay, said Shrek.
I will get your tip from my bag.
You eat my food, said the cloud that made the lightning.
Shrek reached into his bag for his gun that killed clouds.
Yeah!
I've got to read this book.
It's real.
Will you press the button?
You can eat lightning bolts, but you have to kill the clouds.
Produce the lightning bolt.
I think I would.
I would, would, would.
Oh, wait.
Wait, there's another one.
That's the same picture, but diff...
Okay, I think it's edited.
What is... what...
Wait, is this the real thing?
Now I can't...
Now I don't know.
Wait, now I don't know what's real.
This one.
Fat raindrops began sizzling on Shrek's hot knob.
Did you ever see something so disgusting, said lightning to thunder?
Never, thunder growled.
Let's give him the works.
Lightning fired his fierce bolt straight at Shrek's head.
Shrek just gobbled it, belched some smoke, and grinned.
Lightning, thunder, and rain departed.
They just laughed!
Is this real?
Is what?
What's a hot knob?
His head?
Is it those little... the little bump?
I think it's the bump on his head, you guys.
Yes, that is the real book.
So would Christian be the minotaur or the farmer?
No way!
I think it's the thing on the top of his head, right?
The little lump on his head?
The actual book is more ridiculous than the edit.
Which is real?
Well, I don't think the first one is real.
Is this one?
This one seems more real.
The first one seems a little...
I don't think Shrek has a gun.
Oh, that's a stick.
That's not a gun.
Oh my gosh.
I thought it was a gun.
Okay.
Nicole!
Welcome to Banboship.
Thank you!
I'm gonna not press the button because I don't really care about Kristen Stewart.
And also...
I don't feel...
I feel...
I don't...
I mean...
I don't see a very good side to this.
Most people didn't care.
Most people were like, whatever.
Who would play Mint Phantom?
Phantom.
Minto.
Fantomo.
Will you press the button?
You will have the force but you will become a...
It's my dream.
It's my dream to become a cat!
I just wanna be...
Jack Black!
Oh my gosh.
I would love Jack Black to play me.
In the movie?
Jack Black!
Jack Black in the movie!
What's the downside?
Yeah!
You become a cat!
I see no downside at all here.
I've always wanted to become a cat.
I think...
I always think...
You know...
If I ever can become reincarnated...
Since I'm already dead...
If I can ever be born again...
I want to be a cat.
I want to be born as a cat.
I want to be born as a cat...
In...
In a house...
Where I'm just loved...
And...
I just get to lay around...
And do nothing.
All the time.
Cat that shoots lightning?
What is the force?
The force is like being able to...
Move stuff with your brain.
Right?
That's it?
Will you be a poopy cat?
Maybe.
It's a trick.
Cats already have the force.
Mint.
I am your father.
Meow.
Mint.
Now I kick telekinesis.
Telekinesis...
Mind control...
Lightning!
You guys, if I press this, I only have one more shot...
Before I'm out.
I only have one more button press.
I only have one more...
Also, easy to see...
328 comments.
People were very passionate about this one.
I only have one more.
Well, the force is an energy field...
Most people pressed it.
Wow.
Alrighty.
What I will do is... let's do 10 more.
Let's do 10 more.
And within that 10, I can only do one.
Okay?
So I'm gonna say...
Left 10.
I'm gonna move it over here.
So we have 10 more.
And then...
I can only push the button on one of them.
You become a member of your favorite musical group.
But the person you end up replacing will completely...
No!
I would never.
Do not press.
The person who you end up replacing will completely cease to exist.
Like...
If I become a member of my favorite musical group...
I wouldn't even be a member...
I wouldn't even be probably so much of a fan if they didn't exist.
I will not press.
And I'm glad most people have taste.
Alright, 9 left.
Okay, guys.
Next.
Oh!
Ah!
I will not press.
Too much text.
Mucho texto.
Next.
I'm not gonna count that one.
You are amazing football player.
But you have to be half human, half eagle.
What in the My Hero Academia?
This one has no downsides.
You are an amazing football player.
But you have to be half human.
I'm bird person.
I think I'm already half eagle a little bit.
But the eagle...
Flies higher...
Above the clouds.
Blblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblbl.
Press it.
No.
What are the upsides?
I'm half eagle.
What are you talking about?
I'm a harpy at that point.
I'm a harpy.
No.
Is this the American dream?
I think so.
I'm sure there might be some people...
Some EU watchers...
Today...
Because...
My stream is...
A little bit early...
This is it.
This is the American dream!
Pay my monthly rent to the half eagle man.
Thank you!
Soaring puts.
Aren't you already a cat?
No!
Imagine just flying over the competition going, Your flightless legs are useless against me!
The downside is now that you have to live in Philadelphia.
Why?
Oh, I still have my mustache on.
I forgot.
Sorry.
The revolution is over.
Forget the age of 30, I hear monster girls are in demand.
I mean, I'm a ghost, so I'm technically a monster girl.
Right?
I think I'm technically a monster girl.
I mean, I'm in the Monster Girl Encyclopedia.
So...
I mean...
You know, so...
I hear ghosts are in demand.
What was this?
I really want to become an eagle.
I want to become half eagle.
You guys, anything from here on out, if I push this button, anything else, we're going to have to not push the button!
Or else I'm going to get punished!
You can't touch a ghost.
10 monster GF?
Okay, hold on.
Hold on!
0 out of 10!
Give me at least one point!
Because...
I can still possess you.
And also...
I mean, no, you can't really touch me.
But I mean, there's also ectoplasm.
Don't think too hard about it, okay?
Take the punishment like a boss.
Push the button, because eagles are free!
Why did most people not push the button?
What the...
Most people did not push the button!
Why?
What's the downside?
You are conscious in your dreams but you only have nightmares.
Where is the good side?
Where is the good side of this one?
Cowards.
They were all cowards.
There is no good...
This one is actually so bad.
Why would I want to be conscious in my dreams if they're just nightmares?
Why would that be good?
Maybe because then if I'm conscious I could be like, oh, this is just a nightmare.
Or rather, this is just a dream.
It's no big deal.
I won't be so scared of it, I'm guessing.
Is the thought process...
No.
Get this out of here.
You will swap genders but you will still have the same personality and relative attractiveness as before.
So I'll be fucking ugly!
I will not push the button!
What?
Anyway...
This is only bad for me.
If I still have the same personality and everything I'm just gonna be actually a terrible, ugly idol ojisan and all my idols will hate me.
I can only be an ojisan because I'm a girl and so it's...
Oh,
come on!
I can only be an ojisan but I'm still a girl.
Let's see...
Oh wait, uuh.
Uh.
What.
Left is seven
You can sleep with anyone you choose but every other person has to be someone you don't want to sleep with.
I like sleeping by myself though...
It's too hot in the bed.
I will not be pushing the button.
What's the good side of this?
It's just disrupting my sleep schedule.
Wow, most people didn't press the button.
Next!
6.
Oh, not 56, 6.
So far these are...
not so bad.
Half-Life 3 will be released for free for everyone.
But you can never play it.
Take one for the team.
Save the people, Mint.
That's a freebie?
No, no, no.
There are no freebies.
Remember that Henya wants Half-Life 3?
Hero.
I'll be your hero.
Hold on.
I need some dramatic music.
What the hell?
Why are all these playlists?
Hold on.
I don't know how dramatic this is, but I'm gonna play it.
I've never played Half-Life.
But...
for everybody's sake.
For everybody's sake.
Who's been waiting for Half-Life 3.
All those years that you've been waiting.
Hoping.
Praying.
Wishing.
On a fallen star.
Someday, please.
Release.
Release Half-Life 3.
And I hope...
I hope it's a great one.
I hope...
I hope it's the greatest disappointment of your life!
I hope you waited 20 years, 84 years for shit!
I hope it comes out and I never play it.
I can never play it.
And I hope it's terrible for all of you guys!
And it will be the worst!
Oh my god.
And it's going to be awful!
It's going to be so bad!
You're going to be so disappointed!
Yeah!
Uh...
Um...
Anyway.
Where were we?
Um...
Uh...
Oh yeah.
Most people didn't press it.
I contributed to the green.
To lighten up this moment, has Mint heard the Burger King rep commercial about Spongebob's square ass?
This is real.
I've never heard that.
Uh...
Half Life 3 is going to be a live service game.
Oh...
Done...
Next.
You can make anything taste like what you want it to.
But you will be constantly hungry.
Oh no no no.
Constantly hungry?
Then what's the point of even eating what I want?
What's the point?
Half Life 3 but with Blue Archive characters?
Okay then...
Do you want the greatest game ever?
Put Blue Archive characters in anything and I'll be happy.
You should let Hanya decide your punishment.
Okay.
Um...
I will not.
And most people agree with me.
...
What if you could stay alive forever but you cannot communicate with anyone but yourself?
Um...
I...
Who?
Okay.
Alexa play break sound.
Um...
This is like...
Wait.
Do people actually want to stay alive forever?
Chancellor!
Thanks for the 10 gifts!
Do people actually want to stay alive forever?
Like is that actually something?
Like if people ever just think about it for just a tiny moment.
Like just a tiny moment.
And also.
You cannot communicate with anyone but yourself.
It would be so bad.
We get boring fast.
Right?
This is like a huge trade off.
So no.
Okay.
Next.
Three.
You get your own free private jet.
And a lifetime supply of jet fuel.
In-flight snacks.
Drinks.
In-flight movies.
And a busty flight attendant.
But the busty flight attendant.
But the bust...
A private jet will one day be used in a massive terrorist attack.
You do not know which day that will be.
Um.
But then they'll die!
You guys I can't because the busty flight attendants will then cease to exist.
I think.
I think they'll die on the plane.
That would be so sad.
That would be so sad for them.
And the world.
Being deprived.
Less booba.
Save them.
By.
But also.
What if we do invent.
Um.
Oh wait.
It says you get your own free private jet.
And a lifetime supply of jet fuel.
In-flight snacks.
Drinks.
What do you mean snacks?
What are we talking about?
Like those tiny bags of pretzels.
That has two pretzels in them.
I don't want snacks.
I want a whole ass meal.
Save the booba.
Save the busty.
This is literally.
This is.
Are you guys for save the animals.
Or kill the animals.
That's a GDQ question.
Save the busty flight attendants.
Or kill the busty.
Hold on.
Let's make a poll.
Okay guys.
Save or kill.
Save the busty flight.
Attendants.
Kill the busty flight.
Start.
Save the animals.
Oh!
Did it go?
Oh there it is.
Oh.
Wow a lot of people for saving them.
Oh I spelled attendance wrong.
That's okay.
Save the booba!
Save the BFA.
Save the frames.
Kill the animals.
Most people are saying, save the bus, save flight attendants.
Flying is miserable anyway.
I don't mind flying so much, I'll be honest.
Greetings from Germany.
First time watcher.
Long time chatter.
Save the attendants.
Thank you, implode!
Plot twist.
The attendants are the terrorists.
And what if my jet is actually Metal Gear?
What are their demands?
Big boss's body?
Even with that free, planes will bankrupt you.
That's true.
No more business class feet.
True!
Now it's getting interesting.
Most people say, save the BFA.
Goodbye, frames.
I will not be.
Wow, most people said no.
Most people also believe in the BFA.
Let's see, next.
Everything you say will come true, but you will get the opposite of what you say.
This is just like a monkey paw thing, isn't it?
What is the good side of this?
Take the jet and sell it.
Keep the BFA.
Then it's out of my hands.
I wash my hands of this.
What if one of the attendants is just awesome?
And a skirt and an open blouse?
I don't think he is busty enough.
Is he busty enough?
I don't know.
Just say the opposite.
So say, everything I say won't come true.
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Say...
Say, I...
Everything I say...
Wait.
How do you phrase this?
Say all the negative.
Oh, yeah.
Gosh, I wish I won't have a busty flight attendant.
I don't want one million dollars in my bank account.
But then, what if you accidentally say something that...
What if you accidentally...
What if you accidentally mess it up?
This one is a scam.
I feel like it's too easy to slip up, you know?
It's too easy to slip up, I think.
Get rid of it after your best wishes.
Right?
I will not be pressing the button.
Okay, guys.
Wow, he only pressed it one over.
This one is also...
Wait.
You can become invisible, but it works only one minute every day.
What's the downside?
That it's a minute?
Who cares?
It's a free minute.
There's no downside.
Hold on.
You guys...
Let's skip this one.
It's just a net good.
Can I press it but not count?
Actually, can I just skip it?
Yeah, there needs to be a downside for it.
But you're a ghost anyway.
Yeah, it doesn't really even pertain to me.
I'm in your rooms all the time.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Skip, skip.
I'm the minority.
Okay.
You get 3,000 pounds.
Or US$3,000 for Brits per day.
But you cannot exchange it for your local currency.
Hahaha.
So I just move to...
I just move there?
Like...
What's the downside?
I just get 3,000... 3,000 pounds a day.
Living in England.
Oof.
Just save up and move.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I have to move to the UK.
But it's free money.
You can't exchange it for your local currency.
So like...
What if I go on a trip?
I can exchange it for that currency?
So I could exchange it for like...
I could exchange it to another currency.
It's fine.
I'd rather die than become British.
This one is a great one to end on for our EU friends today.
For those watching in the EU hours.
This one maybe is...
Hahaha.
Is a good one to end on.
Local means wherever you are.
So I'm just stuck in the UK.
I suppose.
Right?
But also...
Also...
Consider this.
If I buy something with a credit card...
It doesn't matter.
What the currency is.
Right?
It just uses it.
So...
I see.
A SIMP.
It doesn't say you can't exchange it for Yen and then buy everything on AmiYami.
So...
I don't know about exchanging things.
Well...
Oh.
2 Yen is fine.
Yeah.
Right?
So...
Bitcoin?
Oh no.
Not the cryptocurrency.
Loophole.
So yeah.
If I just...
Put it...
Have it in my bank account and use my credit card...
It should be fine.
There's no negative.
Push that button!
Well guys...
Oh wait.
I think I...
There we go.
Zero.
Well guys...
I pushed it...
I went over the limit.
I will have a punishment.
I will accept my punishment...
Somehow.
We'll figure something out.
I missed one earlier.
Wait, I did.
Wait, the left or the...
Two punishments.
No!
The limit does not exist.
What have you been watching?
Mean Girls lately?
I don't know.
Oh no.
Ah...
Your punishment is to speedrun MGS1 but you must skip all cutscenes.
That's just torture.
Matara gives one.
Hennia gives one.
Okay I will ask Hennia and I will ask Matara for a punishment.
From each of them.
And I will do a punishment.
From the...
Each of them.
So once...
Once I know the punishment... Here, I'll even message them right now.
I think Matara is streaming.
Oh my god!
This is so cute.
Maya, oh my gosh, if you're still here, I just saw your message.
It just opened up.
Okay, Matara.
Whenever you're free, I lost a challenge on my stream today.
Can you give me a Batsu?
To do?
Sad face.
And Henya.
Where is Henya?
Henya!
I was playing a game on stream and I lost.
So I have to do a punishment.
Crying, crying, crying, crying, crying.
My chat wants you to choose a punishment for me.
Okay.
Whenever I receive these, I will do them, I suppose.
Can you give me a...
Okay, okay, okay.
And it was for Half Life 3.
Hold on, sorry.
I'm responding to something.
I sent that exact emoji.
I sent that exact emoji to Henya.
Of me crying.
The same one.
Both of them.
And also the PN.
PN, PN, PN.
PN, PN, PN, PN, PN, PN.
Okey-dokey, guys.
Wow.
We had some tough ones.
Some of them were really easy.
But some of them were pretty tough.
I'm glad that we are all in agreement.
That we would become eagle people.
Eagle people, rise!
Anyway.
Thank you guys for the stream today.
This was very interesting.
Some of these prompts were crazy.
Thank you.
Kiss.
Thanks for all the button pushing.
Just curious if you saw the trailer for Beetlejuice 2.
I did!
Not sure if he's a ghost role model for you or not.
Oh my gosh!
I did see the trailer!
I saw it last night.
Oh my gosh!
And how Winrider's back.
And they like...
It's all still so campy looking.
It looks so good.
I'm excited.
It looks kind of fun.
I'll probably watch it.
But you have to play football.
No!
But I'm an eagle.
I'm good at football.
It doesn't matter.
I can probably take them all down in one person.
One eagle.
Half person.
I can take them down.
Half person, half eagle.
Melanie, thanks for the 10 gifted!
No, I just got here, PN.
Sorry!
Sorry, sorry.
I'm cautiously optimistic about the movie.
Looks like they're still using stop motion.
Yeah!
I know.
It's really cool.
So...
I've never seen Beetlejuice, but the broadcast is so good.
Oh!
I've seen some clips from the Broadway show.
It looks funny.
It looks interesting.
So...
Why not?
If you guys say my name three times, I might appear.
But sometimes...
Uhh...
Sometimes...
It only feels like if I wanna appear.
Sometimes I don't wanna appear.
You know?
So...
It's like when you call to a cat.
You're just like...
Come here, cat!
Sometimes they come, sometimes they don't.
It's the same with me.
You can try.
Try saying Mint Phantom, Mint Phantom, Mint Phantom and I might appear.
I don't know.
Depends on how I feel, you know?
So, you can go ahead and try it.
I don't know.
Matara sent me one too.
Oh my god.
No!
Hena sent me one.
She sent me the game of Sisyphus.
She wants me to play as a Sisyphus.
And Matara sent me one.
She said kiss me on the mouth.
No.
Something else.
It's not that bad though, is it?
It can't be that bad.
I saw Fauna cleared it, right?
Randall!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you so much!
Can't be that bad, right?
Fauna just ran up the hill.
She cleared it without touching the boulder.
Oh my god.
God Gamer.
Well, then I... then I'll... do... I'll... I'll... play it, I guess.
Wait, hold on.
Uh-oh, my YouTube is frozen.
I'm just gonna look at chat from here.
I meant about that pole.
Don't worry about it.
Don't even... don't even worry about it.
If you say phantom three times fast, you get a big phantom appreciate power time.
Wait, what?
Oh no, wait, this doesn't work either.
I can't... I can't see or... I can't... I can't scroll up, so I can't read it.
Hold on.
One second.
There we go.
You get big phantom appreciate power time when you're in the gym.
Phantom game... gains.
Get the phantom gains, everybody.
You get fap time.
No!
Thank you guys for watching my stream!
Thank you!
I will see you guys tomorrow.
I will be not streaming.
I will be at Anime North in the parking lot, baby!
But thank you guys for helping me make these super-duper difficult decisions.
I guess I will play as a Sisyphus before... before...
Before...
Oh, Matarai says...
Matarai is still coming up with the punishment.
And I will play as a Sisyphus sometime.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
And I will see you... later...
Bye men.
Bye Bechtel Bill!
Thank you for a month!
Bye bye!
Have a good day!
Thank you!
Woo!
Mario Kart Wii!
Woohoo!
Actually, hold on.
That's going to be the ending music today.
You got the golden star!
Get coconut mauled!
I don't remember the middle of the song!
You just got coconut mauled!